plus chers compatriotes après avoir
menacé d'interdire une manifestation
syndicale demain avoir décidé de mettre
en oeuvre cette interdiction
le gouvernement a finalement décidé
d'autoriser la manifestation qui lave
dont il avait annoncé l'interdiction
plus personne n'y comprend rien il n'y a
plus d'autorité dans le pays et la seule
chose qui est vrai c'est que c'est la
cgt qui menace et la cgt auquel le
gouvernement obéit ce gouvernement qui a
une nouvelle fois donner aux français
l'illustration de ce qu'est la perte
d'autorité et de tout contrôle sur la
situation
c'est un aveu d'impuissance cet amant de
fermeté et c'est une marque coupable de
faiblesse au fond c'est la conséquence
logique d'un 49,3 que je n'ai jamais
utilisé en cinq années de président de
la république
voilà donc un gouvernement qui interdit
au parlement de débattre puis qu'il veut
interdire aux manifestants de manifester
puis qui cède à la pression des mêmes
manifestants les républicains demandent
au gouvernement de réagir de réagir avec
off de la fermeté cela signifie de
rétablir les peines planchers
automatique pour les agresseurs de
dépositaire de l'autorité publique
nous n'avons pas à tolérer l'action de
casseurs qui sont connus par les
services de police
seule la ferme des manques pour les
empêcher de nuire
nous proposons qu'au delà de l'état
d'urgence il soit désormais en france
possible d'interdire préventivement par
voie administrative aux casseurs
présumés de se joindre aux
manifestations en les faisant par
exemple pointer au commissariat ou à la
brigade de gendarmerie le temps de la
manifestation
après tout c'est ce qui a été décidé
pour les hooligans pour les casseurs
dans les stades
il faut utiliser la même mesure pour les
casseurs
à l'extérieur des stades et enfin je
demande au nom des républicains une
nouvelle fois l'engagement systématique
de la responsabilité civile et
financière des organisateurs de
manifestations suivies de violences et
d'incidents la cgt
lorsque c'est d'elle dont il s'agit doit
faire face à ses responsabilités
dans une démocratie est normal que les
syndicats puissent manifester mais quand
il manifeste qui a des dégâts physiques
matérielles qu'il ne doit pas y avoir
d'impunité
c'est la cgt qui doit assumer ses
responsabilités ce n'est pas le
contribuable qui doit payer pour la cgt
en démocratie le droit de manifester est
une liberté qui doit être respecté mais
dans la république le droit de
manifester ne serait s'exercer sans
respect de l'ordre et de la sécurité
il serait temps que le pouvoir actuel se
montre à la hauteur d'un enjeu qui peut
conduire à de graves débordements
parce que la faiblesse du pouvoir
entraîne la violence des débordements